[Musique]
vous les avez vu danser à ibiza vous les
avez vous surprendre en jeu à las vegas
vous allez les adorer à shanghai la
ville de toutes les libertés
[Musique]
voilà
booba
jeudi à shanghai tu as pu pourquoi ça
pue là c'est quoi ce bazar et le
maroilles et les futurs à la flotte
partout là c'est quoi ce même rame
offert le maroilles nostalgia n'est qu'à
laisser la france du frigo ouverte aux
quais et maintenant tout les congèle de
da elle s'en foutait comme on a shanghai
je vous rends pas compte comment c'est
dur de trouver du fromage au japon tu
crois bah fallait pas que jordan était
jeune il se bat pour des broutilles
c'est beau la radio rentrée méthodes aux
ja un nouveau chic arrive à la villa
j'espère que le nouveau ch'tis vont
ouvrir la terre le battait qu'elle vous
[Musique]
et là il arrive et on le voit salut moi
c'est jordan gross d'apple
[Musique]
ah mais oui mais je te connais tu es pas
de la famille à steve de tourcoing le
tout ça hu
comme tout comme kia sportage kg il est
pas méchant le nouveau mais juste il a
des problèmes au niveau de la halle a
promis scruter ut qui ce qui laisse
traîner des merdes comme ça de la
baignoire là haut c'est beau rire voici
un poisson pour le coach ordonne brian
regarder chanial en le nouveau dans sa
chambre au sommaire en volume est
classique est venu mettre la zone à
noter que lui faut toujours qu'ils
videraient toutes les races et tout ce
qui vient du soleil tous ceux qui
viennent ici donc voulait bien le chien
se met l'otan est au ça va pas du tout
là ton truc ce n'est pas normal ça va
trop vite là ça pousse trop lente
normal les toits on est tous d'accord
pour dire ici que tu parle jamais et on
sait pas si tu es un vrai ch'ti hockey
et on ne sait pas si tu sais faire des
choses pour montrer que tu sais faire
des choses pour travailler dans l'ana et
ou pas alors qu'est ce que tu as à dire
des joies mais aussi des peines une
chose est sûre les ch'tis ne vous
laisseront pas indifférent c'est la
reine de la neige
[Musique]
dans le prochain épisode
vous verrez comment ils vont combattre
la race alien qui est sorti du ventre de
shania que tu veux chauffeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]